check out this fine-looking sneaker
right here we're going to use this shoe
to illustrate some more challenging
normal force problems and we're going to
take this as an opportunity to discuss a
lot of the misconceptions that people
have about the normal force so one
misconception is that people forget
normal force is a contact force
you only have a normal force when two
surfaces are in contact so when the
shoes in contact with the floor there'll
be a normal force on the shoe and a
normal force on the floor or if the shoe
were in contact with the wall there'd be
a normal force on the wall and a normal
force on the shoe but if the shoe were
just falling through the air here's what
happens for a lot of people let's say
the shoe just falling and you got a
question and the question said draw the
forces that are exerted on the shoe
while it's falling through the air
people get so used to having normal
forces that they make a mistake they do
this they say all right let me draw it
over here they say there's a
gravitational force and that's just fine
there will be a gravitational force
there's always gravity the Earth's
always pulling down and it pulls down
with an amount mg but they're so used to
having normal forces I mean normal
forces pop up in so many different
questions it's almost just like a reflex
people just automatically put what
there's a normal force there's got to be
a normal force right there's always a
normal force but there isn't always a
normal force if the shoe is not in
contact with the surface you don't have
a normal force it's not until this shoe
makes it to the ground or touches
another surface that you'll have that
normal force so if we stick the shoe
right here and we let it rest on the
ground now you'll have a normal force
and that normal force will point up and
this is what people want to say and it's
true when the surfaces are in contact
but if they're not in contact you don't
have a normal force and then here's
another misconception people think the
normal force is always equal to mg
because again it's equal to mg in so
many different scenarios that people
just want to say well it's always equal
to mg and again it's just like a
reaction people see normal force they
just automatically replace it with mg
and that'll be true in this simple case
but I'll show you coming up how that's
not going to be true and what you do if
it's not true so for instance if we
wanted to find what's the normal force
if this shoe has a mass M let's assume
the shoe has a mass M
what would the normal force be we can
use Newton's second law we can always
use new
second law so we'll say that
acceleration equals the net force
divided by the mass and in this case
since these are vertical forces I'm
going to consider the acceleration in
the vertical direction and the net force
in the vertical direction and so what is
the acceleration for the shoe vertically
if it's just sitting here in a room
sitting on the ground at rest and not
changing its motion not changing its
velocity the acceleration is just going
to be zero so the vertical acceleration
acceleration excuse me should be zero
for the net force I've got an upward
normal force so I'm gonna make that
positive if FN represents the magnitude
of the normal force this would be
positive FN I'm just going to put a
positive here even though I don't really
need it but to show you that it's upward
we're going to consider upward to be
positive and then I've got this downward
gravitational force and if mg represents
the size of the gravitational force I'm
going to put a negative here to
represent that that gravitational force
is down and then I divide by the mass of
the shoe and if I do this I get that
these two forces this net force divided
by the mass has to be zero according to
Newton's second law but I can multiply
both sides by the mass and if I do that
the left hand side is still zero now get
that this is equal to the normal force
minus mg so I'll have normal force minus
mg and if I finally solve for the normal
force
I'll get that the normal force is going
to equal mg and a lot of people are like
yeah I already knew that duh normal
force is always equal to mg but it's
only equal to mg in this case because
those were the only two forces look at
the assumptions we made only two forces
were the normal force and the
gravitational force and we assumed that
the acceleration was zero if you relax
any of those requirements normal force
is no longer going to be equal to mg and
it was on a horizontal surface if you
relax that requirement again there's no
reason to think this has to be in the Y
direction you could have normal forces
in the X direction so let's slowly one
point at a time try to relax some of
these requirements and see what that
does to the normal force in other words
what if we just added another force what
if we let the shoe sit here on the
ground and I push in
down on it so I'm pushing down on this
shoe I'm going to say I'm pushing down
with a force I'll just call it f1 so us
a force of magnitude f1 and it's
pointing downward how would that change
this now so this is we're stepping it up
this is going to be a little harder what
do we do well the acceleration is still
zero let's say it's still just sitting
there so we don't have to do anything
with the left hand side that's still
zero multiplying by M still makes that
zero but now up here in this force up
here I'm going to have another force I'm
going to have f1 that points down so in
my force diagram I'd have another force
that points down f1 that means I'd have
to subtract it when I find the net
vertical force I'd have f1 this would be
a negative f1 right here and when I
solve for FN I'd add mg to both sides to
cancel it and then I'd add F one to both
sides to cancel this f1 this negative f1
and I'd get mg plus f1 so I get the
normal force is going to be bigger
bigger by an amount f2 and that makes
sense if you push down on oh not f2 Wow
f1 sorry about that it's going to be
bigger by an amount f1 so if I push down
with an extra 10 Newton's of force
there's more pressure right that makes
sense the pressure between the ground
and the shoe is going to be greater
you're squashing these two surfaces
together with greater force so the
ground is got to push up to keep the
shoe out of the surface that's what this
normal force does it exerts a force to
keep the object out of the surface to
keep the object from penetrating that
surface so if I push down on an object
into a surface that normal force
increases and it increases by the amount
you're pushing down so that makes sense
if you had an upward force let's say you
had an upward force someone's pulling up
on the shoe while you push down you're
fighting over the shoe you're wrestling
over it with somebody because they just
they love the shoe they recognize the
beauty this shoe well-crafted shoe so if
there's an f2 pointing up we now have
another force on our diagram that force
would point up we'd call this f2 over
here how would this change again still
acceleration is zero but I'd have an
upward force now so I'd have to add f2
vertically because that's another force
I'd have a plus f2 right here and then
over here when I solve for this I said I
add mg to both sides
f12 both sides and I have to subtract F
2 from both sides so now I'd have FN is
mg plus F 1 minus F 2 this also makes
sense if you pull up on a shoe you're
relieving some of the pressure between
the shoe and the other surface the shoe
and the floor so if I pull up with 20
Newtons I'm going to reduce the normal
force by 20 Newtons because I'm
relieving some of that pressure between
the shoe and the floor let's make it
even harder let's make this thing scary
sometimes you get really crazy problems
you don't know what to do let's say we
have another force let's say this force
is going to be a diagonal force so we're
going to pull this way oh that was not a
well drawn force let me draw it like
this so we got a force this way at an
angle now how now we're talking this way
this is f3 f3 at an angle of we'll call
it Phi so the angle from this horizontal
line here is Phi now what do we do so
I've got this crooked angle in here now
this f3 is going to be pointing this way
so I'll add another force to my force
diagram and I can figure out how to
include this into my vertical force
version of Newton's second law I can
include the entire f3 force here's a
mistake people make they want to just
add f3 or subtract f3 but I can't do
that this is the vertical form of
Newton's second law this is only
applying to the vertical direction the Y
direction but f3 is pointing both
vertically and horizontally so I have to
only include the vertical part of f3 in
this formula so what I have to do is say
that alright f3 is going to have a
vertical component that vertical
component I'll call it F 3 y 4 F 3 in
the vertical direction and it's also
going to have a horizontal component
I'll just call that F 3 X 4 F 3 in the
horizontal direction so if we want to
solve for F 3 Y I'll just use the
definition of sine and I know to use
sign because this side is the opposite
to this angle I know sine relates
opposite side so I'm going to write this
as sine of Phi is going to equal the
opposite side is f 3 Y so F 3 in the Y
Direction divided by
three total the total magnitude of f3
and if I solve this for f3 why I get f3
and the y direction is going to equal F
3 times sine of Phi now I can include
this in my force my net force because
this points upward so since it points up
this vertical component it's going to
add a plus f3 sine theta over here or
sorry not theta it's going to be F 3
sine Phi and I'll have a plus F 3 sine
Phi right here and when we subtract this
F 3 sine Phi from the other side to get
it over to here we're going to get minus
F 3 sine Phi and that makes sense
because if we pull up we know we're
reducing some of the pressure will
reduce the normal force so this
component look at this component points
up it's reducing some of the pressure on
the bottom of the shoe the normal force
goes down and so we subtract the F 3
sine Phi and one more way to step this
problem up to the next level would be to
say that this room isn't really just a
room maybe it's an elevator and this
elevator is accelerating upward with
some acceleration a zero in that case
nothing would change on this right hand
side sometimes people think if there's
acceleration there's going to be some
new force but if these are the forces
those are the forces the only thing that
changes over here if this was an
elevator that's accelerating up is it
instead of zero you'd replace this with
a zero or whatever the acceleration is
that's it that's the only change you can
still solve for FM the same way when you
multiply by M it wouldn't be zero on the
left anymore you'd have an M a zero and
then a plus M a zero when you solve for
the normal force alright
I think we've pretty much exhausted this
example of a shoe on the floor that's
probably harder than any example you'll
see but now you know how to handle any
type of force you might meet or
acceleration